[Musik]
fleischgeschmack ganz ohne fleisch das
versprechen zumindest einige
veggieburger sebastian lege verrät uns
was in welcher bürgern drin steckt und
wie geschmack konsistenz und optik der
fleischhaltige originale nachgebildet
werden
[Musik]
galkin slacker bürger zum feiern haben
was davon
leckere burger haben mittlerweile auch
in deutschland tradition die hauptzutat
ein saftiges petit aus rindfleisch genau
so sollen bürger petit aussehen schönes
rautenmuster richtig heiß cross gegrillt
lecker doch mit dem original haben die
paddys auflege grill nichts zu tun was
wie fleisch aussieht besteht hier aus
rein pflanzlichen zutaten und liegt
damit voll im trend
supermärkte und discounter bieten immer
häufiger sogenannte veggie burger
komplett ohne fleisch dafür aber
ordentlich teuer lohnt sich der griff zu
den neuen produkten
wir versprechen trotz pflanzlicher
zutaten sollen die bürger nach fleisch
schmecken
sebastian lädt alle zum gesundheitlich
unbedenklichen test und lecker sonst ist
kalle kein baby fan
doch wie schafft es die industrie
fleischgeschmack so gut zu imitieren ich
weiß wie es funktioniert
in seiner werkstatt zeigt läge im
kleinen was industriell im großen passt
das ist ja schon ein kleiner zaubertrick
aus pflanzlichen produkten ein
originalen fleischgeschmack zu erzeugen
dazu braucht es eine menge zutaten als
vorbild hält sich läge an das original
aus rindfleisch dessen konsistenz belege
zuerst kopieren locker und gleichzeitig
bissfest beim rindfleisch sorgt der ruhe
proteingehalt für die strukturen und 20
gramm eiweiß stecken in einem pd
die muss lege jetzt endlich liefern um
eine textur zu erschaffen genauso wie
fleisch braucht man natürlich ein
alternatives protein also eine
eiweißquelle hier haben wir erbsen
eiweiß weizeneiweiß
die sorgen schon mal für diesen bis
walfleisch haben einen gewissen
widerstand im mund und die möchte
natürlich pflanzlich genauso erzeugen
kümmern auch wenn einige pflanzen wie
erbsen sind wahre protein bomben
mithilfe technischer verfahren kann die
industrie die eiweiße heute aus den
pflanzen auswaschen in pulverform bilden
sie die basis für den bad iburger
weiter geht es mit dem geschmack
fleischig herzhaft muss das petit
schmecken
auf dem grill entwickeltes zudem
feineren aromen eigentlich ist das
einzigartig doch lege weiß auch einige
gewürze enthalten ähnliche aromen
richtig kombiniert imitieren sie
fleischgeschmack tomaten pulver sellerie
pulver rote beete pulver granulat salz
knoblauch pfeffer
doch dann greift lege zum
geschmacksverstärker umami
eigentlich heißt so unsere fünfte
geschmackswahrnehmung neben den vier süß
sauer bitter und salzig
doch die industrie kennt auch perfektes
umami aroma aus hefeextrakt in
pulverform kommt dass in den veggie
burger für einen leicht blutigen
geschmack nutzt lege eine spezielle
zutat reisen tabletten
denn auch fleischsaft enthält eisen
backe backe rindfleisch partie fehlen
noch resta roaming was sich beim grillen
von fleisch von allein bildet muss lege
seiner version künstlich mit hilfe von
soja sauce und rauch aroma verleihen
schauen sie sich das mal an
aus einem grauen pröll welchen langsam
eine rot fleischige masse die grundlage
für den fleischlos burger ist damit
fertig wahnsinn das hat schon so eine
faser ähnliche struktur wie rindfleisch
kurier
tatsächlich kommt die version von
sebastian optisch dem original sehr nahe
fehlt noch der typische hackfleisch look
eine kernige raue oberfläche in saftigem
rosa versetzt mit kleinen fed stückchen
zum verfestigen vakuumiert sebastian die
bürger masse jetzt und er hilft sie
anschließend im wasserbad
[Musik]
sieht schon ein bisschen aus wie das
gulasch meiner mutter am sonntag eine
reibe verwandelt nun die gulasch brocken
in hackfleisch imitat rote beete pulver
sorgt für den typisch rosa fleisch look
fehlt noch das feld tiefgekühltes
kokosfett da bekommen wir diese
typischen kleinen fähnchen bin unser
pflanzliches hackfleisch das feld sorgt
nicht nur für die typische optik wie
beim original gibt es auch dem veggie
burger zarten schmelz zusätzlich
verstärkt fed die aromen und gewürze
schon mal kurz um form bringen da es ist
unser veganes bürger petit grillfleisch
experiment geglückt zumindest optisch
kann die wii version mit dem original
aus fleisch mithalten aber für
fleischliebhaber zählt vor allem der
geschmack auf den marktplatz in
düsseldorf macht er produktentwickler
die entscheidende kostprobe auf dem
grill handelsübliche burger auf erbsen
basis genau wie in sebastian tritt das
wird heute ein spaß
bin echt mal gespannt ob meine probe es
war das gleich raus schmecken was ich
den hier servieren gebraten oder
zwischen zwei brötchenhälften sie per
die bürger aus wie das original
erkennen die tester den schwindel
hey du bist ja so philosophie an ich bin
der sebastian ich hab gedacht ich lade
heute die menschen auf dem karlsplatz im
offenburger mag zu bürgern gehören ja
dann auch mal rein passt ja sebastians
verkostung stößt auf reges interesse
[Musik]
und da mussten wir gleich mal sagen
wonach schmeckt das aufflammen typen
du wirst auch lampen gute dass er sagt
ich glaube das schwein mit regen
gewünscht ist ist kein werk haben sie
schon mal sagen
inoffiziell frisch theorie war auch
nicht dabei
also kein normales fleisch
schweinefleisch oder so was aus mir
normalerweise gekündigt auf den ersten
biss bezweifelt niemand dass es sich um
fleisch handelt nur die sorte die lässt
sich einfach nicht bestimmen
auf den zweiten bis werden die zweifel
größer weiß ich nicht oder verrate ich
noch nicht ich würde sagen das ist was
veganes und der konsistenz hier bürger
sind immer aus fleisch versorgen war
kein fleisch
trotz fleischgeschmack einige tester
erkennen den schwindel
leider ist euer gefühlt so gut geschult
es ist rein pflanzlich als alternative
coolen würde es mir kaufen ja
grundsätzlich ja leute dabei die hessen
wollen und dann wird es schade dass ich
keine tupperdose auch wenn sie
geschmacklich nicht ganz an rindfleisch
herankommen
die vegetarischen burger konnten bei den
test es an punkten
viele verbraucher greifen zu
babyprodukten weil sie die umwelt
schonen und ihrer gesundheit etwas gutes
tun wollen
aber sind die alternativen wirklich
gesünder als das original
bei den veganen oder vegetarischen
burgern kommt das völlig darauf an wie
ist dieses produkt zusammengesetzt es
ist so dass teilweise sehr sehr viel
salz eingesetzt werden muss damit die
produkte überhaupt dem fleisch ähnlich
sind mehr als in fleischhaltige bürgern
und natürlich brauche ich oft auch
zusatzstoffe und aromen damit das
produkt auch wirklich schmeckt wie
fleisch wenn die bürger aus supermarkt
und discounter sind ausgeklügelte und
hoch verarbeitete industrieprodukte sie
benötigen eine menge zutaten um den
natürlichen fleischgeschmack zu
imitieren
[Musik]
doch beim thema umwelt ist der veggie
burger im vorteil
natürlich kann man davon ausgehen wenn
nur pflanzliche inhaltsstoffe benutzt
werden dass es dann auch nachhaltiger
für die umwelt besser ist denn die
produktion von fleisch und gerade von
rindfleisch benötigt sehr viel wasser
erzeugt sehr viel co2 und da sind die
pflanzlichen alternativen relativ egal
wie sie zusammengesetzt sind immer
besser und das gilt nicht nur für burger
paddys sondern auch für eine reihe
weiterer fleisch ersatzprodukte wie
bolognese oder wg frikadellen für
verbraucher die ihren fleischkonsum
reduzieren aber nicht ganz auf den
geschmack verzichten wollen ein
nützlicher trick der industrie
was haltet ihr von dem veganen
fleischersatz und welche welche produkte
schmecken euch am besten schreibt es uns
in die kommentare
und wo es die besten lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt zeigen wir
euch auf unserem kanal zdf besser esser